welcome to this video yeah and it's
Yardbird again one of the most frequent
and dangerous opponents Grandmaster
LeBron let's see we get the bogo the
bogo yeah and try something slightly
different gel trying a new line here
let's see yeah this is certainly of
course a possible reply not super
dangerous for black but of course
possible for wired to play Queen takes
is a little bit more critical but let's
see what we what we get um yeah how do I
play this no knight c6 not sure that I
want to do that I can play d 5 of course
and then I then I can go back I can
maybe put it on the aid hmm maybe let's
try that the interesting idea
the ideas that after later move of the f
porn the night can count to have seven
this is very young I'm comparable to
line that I'm playing in the in the in
the Royal pass the chi Goran is let's
see maybe it is a bit bit to pass
affirmed and how to tell but okay we are
we going to see it soon enough um what
should I my aware of it should i take
the chance to play c5 here i think i
should if he takes now i take with the
night and that's very really nice for
black and this way i have the center
blocked yeah he can play so i can even
consider 8585 b6 come on let's do that
make sure that this is some this is
traded to the whole Queen side if he
goes III before I mean so that I don't
have any porn left of the queenside like
takes takes b6 ok
and dooney and absolutely need to get
the night or sun night nighty a g6
nitrous and that's that's really slow g6
be for text eggs b6 maybe this is all
too slow what I'm doing here possible
it's a bit a bit artificial of my plane
let's see let's see him now he's
changing changing gears switching to an
f4 plan interesting
now that certainly have certainly an
idea let's let's see yeah should I just
play of six I guess yeah I need I need
to get the night night to f7 if he goes
f5 yeah I probably have to play g5 yeah
intending to put the night to be five
and interesting okay let's do this first
I was thinking about taking and playing
g5 I wonder if this may be an idea here
fighting for the e5 square ok let's do
that I need to get get some squares yes
I see but I get egg 85 more interesting
interesting position I have c4 attacked
as well I am Not sure that I can take
this ever but I guess King King edge it
I'm not bad not badly positioned here on
the G farm um what happens rook g8 she
ate I can definitely play I cannot take
f6 and now just look f 8 and then see
from down
okay should try to be quick about it as
quick as as possible the night on g7 do
I get it improved somehow I just got 93
f 5 coming Jiggs fatigue rope tricks at
59 probably not a good idea yeah I don't
I really don't know I think I try to
double on the G file with ruchi fire
risk of this one okay
a difficult position okay if it store
mean root ly eight rookies seven nights
i don't i don't really know how bad this
is this is a dangerous bishop of course
but i mean i have the g file
okay but Jim wait wait wait there's some
way to keep keep queens on here probably
not sure how did not Jack
tricky position he's got this before
idea maybe country and trying to enter
my position I can root g one then ok so
let's drop that can before it the right
moment might be tricky and I can take
them take stakes be six at the end I can
always take C form I is really always
pushing may be justified maybe but I
have some open may I have some ideas
with 93 f for Watson maybe I should
should go for that
King age six would also this is Jack
threatens made with rope chief on
pinhook g-form isn't there some made hi
this is never ever good for light never
but I need to still refute it is just
almost almost in a medium
right f3 mate I don't see however who I
can force it
95 jaxxed 95 what does what is he doing
now against it tonight or three mid and
all this is made great I think this is a
mate no I resign yeah he pushed a push
too hard for wind down definitely I
don't know I really don't know where we
come to this way I'm starting to be
better here yeah I feel like under under
some substantial pressure but i am not
i'm not sure it's always very difficult
against him i don't i'm not sure about
the pawn move here really if this is a
good good decision and I computer wants
to play a form which is interesting
tough to play move when you have little
time on the clock it can easily be
exposed to to some attack ya like like
this but yeah maybe it makes sense to to
prevent the B porn from wire for wider
tunes and keep c4 on the fire this is a
computer thinks black as much better
stock Fisher maybe but this also should
be should be good right I wanted yeah
maybe queen age six immediately was
better Jack David here here I think it's
quite clear that only I can be better
yeah maybe a four is better than the
convos it it is very tricky rook h5 the
spectrum yeah of course yeah h5
threatening Knight f3 g5 mate yeah h5 I
didn't see at all now that's so strong
so that's that's just wrong probably
black is winning here minus 3 by the
comp okay I needed to to be quick about
it I decided to
just keep this under control now add the
king is the king is in knots of danger
Jack and this is this is really a win
yeah it is a win of course I can't play
I was ok this is this is a very human
mistake in a way of course I should see
it anyway but I didn't see this year
just winning the book simply because I
wanted to keep the king in this in this
in this this cage let it let it be
trapped and yet probably again I can
play that yeah i can again yeah play
just jam in the rook oh man ok but i
wouldn't mind it a draw here with this
little time cheer and here i'm probably
probably winning right I'm not yet ok-
to something but yeah not not a maid but
after this it's a media made to make
neither three cannot prevent yeah this
was a bit lucky timewise but yeah I good
fight as usually you shouldn't go for
this this pawn grep I guess with the
King being in this much danger of being
mated ok thanks for watching